- We're all adults here,
(laughs)
I would hope that (laughs)
we've reached a point in our lives
where we can buy our own clothes.
(whooshes and squeaks)
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dolisa, I'm from Houston,
Texas and I used to play
hide and go seek with my imaginary friend,
and I never won.
- Hi I'm Chris, I'm from Philadelphia
and my favorite pasta is spaghetti.
- Hi I'm Elena, I'm from Ohio and one time
I won a whole years
worth of free ice cream.
(cheesy music)
- That's really hard,
I don't know how to gauge this.
- Like the questions are gonna have to be,
very strategic.
- Did you ever get like
a bomb Easter basket?
- Yes.
- I don't celebrate Easter.
- Is a majority of your
wardrobe hand me down clothes?
- No.
- I'm already fucking up.
- Was your house the hang out house.
- No.
- No, is the answer to that.
- God.
(pensive music)
- Oh, oh, this might be good.
Can you play monopoly by yourself?
Did you play monopoly as a child?
- Yes.
- Fuck, down to one.
- Did you have your own room?
- No.
- Yes.
- That helps.
- Would your friends describe
you as a loud person?
- Hell yeah.
- My friends would yes.
- Yes.
- I feel like I'm not doing a good job.
- Give me, can I get a lifeline?
Come on!
(pensive music)
- Your parents have a
lot of like report cards
and stuff like that.
- Yeah I would say so.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Geez.
- This is zero help.
- Growing up, did you argue
a lot with your family?
- Yes.
- No.
- I guess like did you
get a lot of presents
for chris-ma-ca?
- No.
- No?
- Yes.
- I guess I'll say yes.
- Okay.
There's my three.
(upbeat music)
The reason why I think this
person is the only sibling,
because the entire time,
all of use were talking
they were like more laid back.
This could be totally
wrong and they could just
be a very shy person but I think it's
you Sarah.
- That is super interesting,
way to determine that.
- What I think the
chances of sharing a room
with a sibling are pretty high.
Based off of that I'm gonna say you
are an only child.
(laughs)
I hope I'm right.
- I'm gonna have to go with Jade.
- No I am not.
(moans) Dang it.
(laughs)
- No.
- You're not.
- I am not.
- I am an only child.
- Yes!
Hell yeah.
(laughs)
- I am an only child.
- You are the only child,
I feel like you would
have been my last guess.
- Its you?
- It's me.
- I'm over this.
- I'm the only child.
- My question was, did
you ever have a bunk bed.
- Oh.
- that's a good on.e
- See I told you you guys would say that.
(whooshes and squeaks)